David, if Trump loses or even if he doesn't,
when he eventually leaves, what happens to
the Republican Party? This is a this is a
big topic. There's really a lot here. And
I think that the wrong analogy would be to look
at the Tea Party. The Tea Party surfaced in 2010
as a sort of libertarian, don't tread on me
reactionary counter to Barack Obama being elected
in 2008. And they got a bunch of people elected to
the House of Representatives. They're presidential
candidates to the extent they had the matter. No.
If, like Ted Cruz is considered a Tea Party guy.
Ron Paul, I think, was a Tea Party guy, but they
never had a prominent presidential candidate
that did well. They never had a president. And
what happened with the Tea Party is they were
essentially some of them just lost and went away.
Their ideas became kind of compartmentalized in
the Tea Party caucus. And they've been more
or less integrated into the Republican Party
as more libertarian leaning Republicans. I
don't think that that applies to what we're
seeing with Donald Trump, because the Trump ism
movement, to the extent that it is a movement
and a lot of that movement is based just around
trigger the liberals. It's a very stupid movement,
but it's arguably a movement nonetheless. They've
got a president who got at least four years and
maybe he'll get four more. And 60 million votes.
Right. That's that's a lot. And maybe maybe more
than that in the upcoming election. So I don't
think that in practice, things are going to
sort of go back to normal. I do believe that
the more traditional Republicans will pretend
that Trump never existed to some degree. They'll
start again talking about, oh, the deficit,
you know, and all the B.S. that they don't really
care about. They'll start blocking any effort. If
it's Joe Biden, any effort that Joe Biden makes
to get anything done, they will maybe even start
fomenting protests, particularly if they lose
the Senate. They'll again kick up the pandering
to the religious right, pandering to the gun
rights people. They're going to do all of those
normal things, but it's going to be tougher to
really pretend top Trump never existed because
Trump got a presidency. And again, the Tea Party
never did that. And I think what will be trouble
is that Trump is not going to fade into the
twilight the way George W. Bush did. We covered
earlier this week. Trump says he might leave the
country if he loses. He. He's been telling all
these states, North Carolina, if you don't vote
for me, I'll never come back. Iowa, if you don't
vote for me, I'll never come back. I do think
that we may see a quieter Trump if he loses. And
certainly if he gets four years and then loses, I
think that that will sort of be the end of Trump.
And we'll be, you know, quite, quite an older guy
at that at that point. But Trump ism and the fact
that Trump has at least three children who seem
to have an interest in remaining in politics,
plus a son in law, plus, you know, all of these
other kind of hangers on. If Trump keeps tweeting
to some degree, if if in the media you continue
to see Don Junior and Erick and Ivana at minimum,
then I think the offspring of this movement will
remain for some time. So I think in practice,
a lot of the future of Trump ism within the
Republican Party is going to be affected by
things we haven't seen yet. One real question, the
Republican Party is going to have to figure out
if Trump loses right now. Okay. Will be how
do we get a handle of the white nationalists,
the people whose ideology is just to anger
liberals, the so-called culture warriors
focused on SJW use and cancel culture. And
that's how that type of thing. How do we get
them under control? Because they're completely
out of control right now. And if Trump loses,
it will be evidence that even with them behind
your candidate, it's not enough to win. If Trump
loses in a moderately large landslide, moderately
large race or in a landslide in a couple of weeks,
the Republican Party is going to have to realize
these groups aren't even helping us win. And
they're really bad for us. We've lost traditional
Republicans because of this group, these groups.
Does the Republican Party abandon those groups?
Do they call them out? Do they just push them
back into obscurity? Still voting Republican, but
not as comfortable with their ideas in public as
they've been under Donald Trump? I don't know.
But all of this put together suggests to me
that whenever Trump leaves, you're going to see
the Republican Party sort of flail about in a
confusion for some period of time after Trump
loses. It may even extend if Trump loses in two
weeks into and beyond the 2022 election, where you
would expect if you have Democrats take. The White
House in this November inaugurated in January.
History suggests Republicans would do well in the
2022 midterms, especially if that didn't happen.
There's going to have to be a real accounting
of what what happens, you know, what happens to
the never Trump Republicans, the Lincoln Project
conservatives, many of whom are supporting Joe
Biden. Do any of them remain Democrats or do
they all go back? All important questions, but
I think it's going to be it's going to take more
than three months to figure out even if Donald
Trump loses in two weeks, which we hope he does.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up, get instant access at Join Patman Icon.